hi
[Music]
mystery recapped here today i'm going to
explain a chinese action thriller film
called kung fu jungle spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
in the opening scene a martial arts
expert named mo walks into the police
station his face is covered in bruises
and cuts that surprise the officers when
asked what happened he answers that he
just killed somebody the officers
quickly call the higher officials and
arrest him it turns out that mo was
fighting an opponent in the ring and
involuntarily killed him during the
match mo knew that what he did was wrong
even though it was accidental hence he
turned himself in the scene cuts to
three years later a police detective
named locke has been called to
investigate a murder crime scene she is
informed that the person who died was a
boxer at first glance a forensic doctor
notices broken ribs and limbs and blood
clots around the eyes detective luck
assumes that the victim must have been
tortured for several days to be that
severely injured but by the nature of
the injuries the doctor claims the
victim probably got into a fight with
someone very skilled they also notice a
strange dagger lying on the crime scene
somewhere else in the penitentiary mo
has been living peacefully for the past
three years he is often ordered around
by a group of inmates with his skills mo
can easily teach them a lesson but he
chooses to avoid any kind of argument
the news of the death makes it to the
television and catches mo's attention he
watches the broadcast in shock almost as
if he knows something about the murder
immediately after he runs to the guard
and asks him to call detective lock the
guard sarcastically questions him about
what else he would like to have mo tries
explaining that he knows something about
the recent murder case but he is
dismissed following that he picks a
fight with a group of inmates the leader
of the group manages to hit him on the
head with a metal plate but mo dodges
the second attack and breaks both of his
arms by now they are surrounded by
policemen who take them under custody
the prison warden knows that mo is not
normally a violent person hence he calls
detective luck and arranges a meeting
between them mo finally meets her and
claims that the person who died was his
former friend who he once fought and
defeated by the nature of the murder mo
is sure that the killer is about to go
on a killing spree he isn't looking for
revenge or money he wants to fight with
the best kung fu fighters fair and
square when asked how he is so sure mo
fails to provide a definite answer but
claims that if they set him free he can
help them find the killer the detectives
assume he is making things up to get out
of prison as they are about to leave mo
recites seven names and declares that
one of them is going to be the next
victim the names are of the fighters who
he has fought and defeated over the
years detective luck doesn't believe him
but she still asks her junior to collect
information on all seven people then we
see the murderer sharpening a dagger and
writing the name king yee on the wall
king yi is one of the people that mo
mentioned earlier he works in an art
museum and is currently working on a
sculpture of a giant human skeleton when
he is alone in the showroom the killer
suddenly appears on top of the skull and
shows his face for the first time he
introduces himself as yu sao and
challenges king yi to a battle they
fight each other on top of the skeleton
when king yi notices that yusau's legs
are different lengths he is wearing a
shoe with a bigger sole to balance
himself they fight using only their legs
but still show great expertise
eventually yuso traps his opponent's leg
between his and breaks it seconds later
he walks away leaving king yi's dead
body behind back in the police station
the detective studies the profiles of
the seven names provided by mo but finds
no similarity in them all of them live
simple lives in different parts of the
city however moe's past seems
interesting to her it is revealed that
he formed a famous martial arts club and
was a teacher before his imprisonment
the club has thousands of followers in
present day he was also recruited by the
hong kong police as a martial arts
instructor as the detectives talk they
get the news about king yi's death
detective luck is shocked that moe's
prediction turned out to be true the
very next day mo is led out of the
prison temporarily under police custody
by inspecting the order of killings mo
has realized that the killer is
targeting his victims by following a
martial arts practice first he killed
the boxer who used his hands then king
yi who used his legs to fight so his
next target will probably be hitmontop i
mean someone who wrestles moe knows a
wrestler among the remaining six people
but yusao gets to the man before the
police when the police arrive at the
location they see the wrestler's body
being thrown from a window he also has a
similar dagger stabbed into his arm
suddenly moe looks at the roof of
another building and sees yusao his evil
smile makes him realize that he is the
murderer mo immediately follows the man
while the police do the same a few
minutes into the chase yusao takes a
leap to the top of a neighboring
building and disappears leaving mo and
the police ashamed that they couldn't
catch him taking the opportunity mo also
escapes from police custody the next day
he goes to his hometown foshon where he
meets his wife xin ying they are happy
to be reunited after three years it is
amazing that the police haven't assumed
this is where he would go she takes him
home and makes him wear a sacred band on
his wrist it is supposed to make him
fight only for self-defense and protect
him from making the same mistake that
got him imprisoned at night mo finds the
killer's dagger in one of the boxes with
his belongings sin ying reveals that a
few months ago a limping man came to
their martial arts school and asked her
to keep the dagger she thinks that the
town's historian might know what the
symbol in the dagger means and the two
decide to go to him the next day then a
flashback shows us yusaw with his late
wife who had cancer she was the only
person in the world who loved and
accepted him as he was while she was
dying he practiced martial arts day and
night to keep himself from thinking
about her inevitable death back in the
present mo and sin ying go to the
historian to find out more about the
dagger it is revealed that the symbol on
it is called eve's swallow during the
rule of the king dynasty it was given to
the person who lost in a martial arts
fight the couple is talking about you
sao when a man nearby overhears them and
claims to know him he says that a few
years ago yusao lived with his cancerous
wife in a nearby town yusao was born
with a disability that makes one of his
legs shorter than the other yet he was
able to master martial arts techniques
with hard work and dedication following
that mo calls detective luck saying that
he has a lead the police immediately
come to the town to receive him and make
their way to the killer's hometown they
arrive at usa's home but see that he has
already moved away the landlady claims
that she never saw yusuf do anything
other than train he also used to rub his
face with salt until it bled to thicken
his skin so it could take a longer
beating then the police find writing on
the wall that says that he has lost
everything in his life and now his only
motive is to fight the best martial
artists and become number one that is
why he has been killing some of the best
fighters and plans to kill more that was
honestly a pretty shallow twist
meanwhile yusao goes to his next target
a former fighter and actor this time he
challenges him to a duel using swords
after a long and fierce match yusau
slits the man's throat and kills him
after yet another death detective luck
is pressured by the higher officials to
solve the case sooner she urges mo to do
the same but he seems to be hiding
something from them once when mo was in
prison he got a letter from yoo sao that
vaguely talked about a challenge back
then mo didn't know what it meant but
now he has realized that he is the final
person usa wants to fight detective luck
also starts to suspect mo and asks the
prison for the cctv footage of every
meeting he has had with an outsider at
night mo is sitting alone in the room
when he remembers the day before the
first murder took place yusao had sent
him a letter asking him to watch the
news the following day the police find
out about yusuf's current address and
send a swat team to his house they
search around it but find no one inside
just as they are about to leave they see
that his wife's ashes are still there
which means he will definitely return to
retrieve them detective luck orders a
redeployment and makes the police stay
hidden until yusau returns to the house
the next morning he is seen approaching
the house on a boat a flashback shows
that his wife was struggling severely
before her death yusao couldn't see her
in such a condition anymore so he mercy
killed her by strangling her to death
that twist was a little more intense in
the present the police see him and
cautiously wait for him to come closer
so they can attack all at once however
you sound notices guard dogs around the
neighborhood and takes a random turn
before anyone knows where he went he is
gone somewhere else an officer
investigating the cctv footage from the
prison finds out that yusao had come to
meet mo while he was in prison detective
locke points her gun at him believing
that the killings were his and yusau's
plan to get him out of prison meanwhile
sin ying has set off to look for yusao
on her own mo swiftly gets hold of the
gun from detective lok and escapes to
pursue yusao and his wife at the same
time xin ying and yusao meet inside of
his house she hands him his wife's ashes
asking him to leave her husband alone
however yu sao believes that if he kills
her mo will become even stronger they
get into a fight and xin ying who is
also a trained fighter gives him a tough
competition but eventually he stabs her
in the arm and runs away mo arrives to
see his wife on the floor and calls for
help he notices you sao just outside the
house and jumps to catch him they land
on a boat and the container with the
ashes breaks while struggling they fall
into the river yusao manages to get on
top of another boat and drives away he
eventually crashes to the boat with
detective luck and the police officers
but disappears soon after mo also runs
away after making sure his wife will be
saved he calls detective luck and tells
her that when he first got yusau's
letter he thought he was only a fan an
only fan seeing his interest in martial
arts mo taught him everything he wanted
to know while he was still in prison he
was unaware that usa would use the
knowledge to kill people mo also knew
that usa was going after sin yang and if
he had told the police everything from
the beginning they wouldn't need his
help hence he kept the secret so he
could come outside the prison and save
his wife himself mo knows who yusow's
next target is using the information he
manages to find yusao in the middle of a
highway on his way to his target's house
although mo has a chance to run him over
he doesn't do it because he wants to
fight him yoo sao is delighted that his
wish is finally coming true the two join
hands to respect each other as opponents
and begin the battle in the middle of
the road almost matching in strength and
skill they are not able to do any harm
to each other for the first few minutes
but then when yusao gets tired mo slams
him to the street where yusao is almost
hit by a vehicle following that they get
a hold of bamboo sticks and fight using
those eventually the bamboos also break
so they fist fight again suddenly mo
ends up under a car that drags him a
little further it is enough to knock him
unconscious taking his opportunity yuso
drags him to the other side of the road
he is about to kill mo but detective
luck arrives at the right time and
shoots him dead in the end mo is taken
to the hospital three months after the
incident he is in prison again detective
luck comes for a visit and informs him
that he is being bailed out shortly in
the last scene we see mo and xin yang
taking pictures with the students from
their school of martial arts subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching